[Musica]
io sarò
nato nel 1964 praticamente uno degli
ultimi verbi boomers
padre operaio specializzato ci teneva a
dirlo e mamma casalinga
mi sono diplomato nel 1984
all'istituto tecnico leonardo da vinci
di firenze a firenze c'erano due
istituti tecnici leonardo da vincere
avendo meno prestigioso il più
prestigioso si chiamava meucci ma ci
andavano i più bravi diciamo così
nel 1984
differentemente da oggi se ti diplomati
avevi già tre o quattro posti di lavoro
non doveva neppure essere bravissimo
bastava e tu fossi bravino io per
esempio mi sono diplomato un 45 e fui
chiamato subito dalla nuova pignone
perché appunto nave libia anche
dell'opinione insieme a la cassa di
risparmio di firenze il monte dei paschi
la galileo era una delle aziende più
ambite potevi andare lì iniziate a
lavorare e andarci anche in pensione con
un po lo stipendio alla sicurezza di una
vita
avevo iniziato l'università in scienze
politiche però dopo due anni smisi
perché farla lavorando era abbastanza
dura e con i primi diciamo risparmi
aveva anche iniziato un po a divertirmi
entrare al nuovo pignone e mi volevano
dopo diciamo due settimane
sarei dovuto andare in libia a vedere
come si montavano le turbine solo che
proprio un po di tempo prima avevo letto
su un giornale che sei tecnici del nuovo
pignone erano fuggiti dalla guerra
civile su un gommone ed erano stati
recuperati da una nave italiana vicino
alle coste libiche
a quel punto diciamo che la mia
la paura diciamo superò di molto la
curiosità è quindi 5 6 giorni e mi
licenziai
fui assunto da un'azienda di milano oggi
si direbbe una start up molto
tecnologica che faceva manutenzione sui
calcolatori bm
lì ho trascorso sette anni della mia
folgorante carriera e
tutto questo per dirvi che
non sono laureato
purtroppo è un mio rimpianto
quindi non sono un bocconiano
non ho studiato nella stanford's a
londra sempre purtroppo e parlo
l'inglese anche malino quel che basta
per lavorare diciamo così però infatti
con tutta l'umiltà possibile però i
fatti dicono che sono il
se riesco a farle girare perché non è
che sono il founder di un'azienda
tecnologica innovativa che oggi a
90 dipendenti
a quattro uffici nel mondo diciamo
milano parigi londra e new york
lavora su delle tecnologie innovative
utilizzando
radiofrequenza intelligenza artificiale
per i più importanti brand del mondo e
quindi oggi non mi sento di lanciare un
messaggio di speranza a tutti quelli che
vogliono iniziare a fare impresa se ce
l'ho fatta io ce la possono fare
veramente tutti questo è il primo
messaggio che vogliono andare voglio
voglio darvi
parlando con diverse persone che sanno
un po della mia
della mia diciamo avventura
professionale perché questa azienda io
l'ho fondata a 45 anni
undici anni fa e dopo una appunto una
carriera come in varie aziende fino ad
arrivare a essere direttore commerciale
avendo saputo di questa di questa mia
avventura che sta andando bene
tutti mi domando partire per fare un
azienda c'è un momento giusto per
partire per fare l'azienda
come vi dicevo io son partito nel 2009
il mondo era in piena crisi perché 15
sempre 2008 me lo ricordo è solo qua
l'imam platea falli so se vi ricordate
appunto oltre a smontare l'insegna
c'erano i poveri dipendenti con gli
scatoloni fuori
perché perché mi ero stufato di dove ero
avevo un'idea che chiaramente con un po
di autostima pensavo fosse essere l'idea
pensavo essere idea milioni del mondo
non conosciamo nulla però della
tecnologia e stava alla base di questi
tempo in di toriale
e
e con un po di risparmi sostanzialmente
in the f r
decisi di partire
scusate ma effettivamente c'è qualche
piccolo problema non è un problema ecco
allora
secondo me
l'età di mezzo è un esausto per per
iniziare a fare impresa 45 50 anni
sempre l'età giusta perché perché
abbiamo l'esperienza
abbiamo la conoscenza del mondo del
lavoro appunto abbiamo forse anche
qualche risparmio ma allora perché
perché tutto il mondo istituzionale dei
finanziamenti eccetera sponsorizza i
giovani che è legittimo farlo ci
mancherebbe altro però attenzione i
giovani non hanno niente da perdere
quando vogliono intraprendere partono da
praticamente zero non hanno niente da
perdere se perdono qualcosa e sono al
punto di partenza
1 all'inizio a fare un'impresa a 45 50
anni qualcosa da perdere cela il sonno
per esempio
la famiglia perché se non voglio dire se
anche abituato a un certo tenore di vita
non accetta forse di ripartire
e quindi io mi sono sempre fatto questa
domanda va bene dare ai giovani ma
perché anche le istituzioni non
sponsorizzano aiutano chi vuole iniziare
una nuova vita
nell'età di mezzo che in questo momento
dopo l'accadimento è stato e purtroppo
c'è ancora
probabilmente servirebbe
io mi sono fatto tantissime volte e
questa domanda ma non ho mai trovato la
risposta
quindi dicevo ero insoddisfatto e aveva
un'idea
l'insoddisfazione la spinta per
ripartire da zero con una nuova
professione
può esser data da da tantissime cose
un licenziamento
il fatto di non sopportare più uno due
tre colleghi
oppure la voglia di rimettersi in gioco
oppure
cercare un cambiamento di vita un
miglioramento della propria vita
professionale
e
[Musica]
attenzione quando io sono partito avevo
questo tema come vi ho detto non non
avevo esattamente
conoscenza di come metterle in pratica
sapevo che questa tecnologia poteva
aiutare queste povere aziende del lusso
a migliorare i suoi processi il proprio
processo a guadagnare ancora di più io
avevo lavorato in un paio di queste
aziende e quindi diciamo che avevo
questa missione da compiere però non
conoscevo esattamente come fare e quindi
mi misi a studiare a studiare leggendo
sui giornali andando in rete tanto è che
mi ricordo benissimo l'otto dicembre
2008 perché c'è nel ponte erano ancora
dipendente perché io poi mi sono dimesso
a fine 2008
con la raccontare una scusa a mia moglie
nel senso che mi disse andiamo a parigi
perché una bellissima città
e nel frattempo avevo comprato un
biglietto di una fiera e parlava di
vista che trattava di questa tecnologia
a led e fans me lo ricordo benissimo lei
si ritrova da sola a generare parigi
mentre io ero a curiosare fra linz tende
a parlare con quattro cinque attori era
un presente sul mercato perché la
tecnologia innovativa in questo senso
quindi non ho non ho fatto non ho messo
in piedi un'impresa
lo so non ho messo in un'officina
meccanica perché stavo facendo in
meccanica come dipendente oppure non ho
pensato a mettere in piedi un servizio
alle uno studio di un servizi alle
imprese perché avevo il padre
commercialista o perché avevo lavorato
vent'anni in uno studio
non ho nemmeno aperto il ristorante
perché sapevo cucinare che è una cosa
che peraltro mi piace malissimo
ma
ho preso questa idea ci ho messo
veramente tanta passione
ho iniziato a studiare e son partito
quindi anche qui se ce l'ho fatta io
ce la possono fare veramente tutti anche
perché alla base di questi da
imprenditori al e c'era la realizzazione
di un software e io neppure da giovane
mi ero divertito a scrivere una riga di
codice un sinclair un comodo che mi fa
tenerezza a vederli ora quindi ecco
veramente e l'altro mio messaggio di
speranza il mio mantra è
se ce l'ho fatta io con questa sua
scolarizzazione con questa conoscenza
delle lingue
diciamo che ce la potete fare davvero
anche con più facilità
quale è però secondo voi l'ostacolo per
mettersi in proprio permettersi per
conto proprio conto proprio renderli da
un termine al cairo contro proprio col
di naomi metto per conto proprio quindi
può far conto solo su me stesso no
questa è l'idea altro di start up sullo
start up arretrano mettiti per conto
proprio poi vedrai
quante mani ti daranno a 50 anni
qual è l'ostacolo secondo voi ve lo
rifaccio qual è ma il principale
ostacolo non c'è nessuno allora vi
faccio vedere io una roba
questi sono e sono i soldi il principale
ostacolo
no perché non servono tanti soldi per
mettere in piedi un'impresa servono i
soldi
per
vivere fino a che le imprese non
guadagnerà servono i soldi per non avere
l'ansia di non farcela perché se uno non
ho una lira inizia a mettere in piedi
un'impresa 50 anni insomma ecco poi se
gli affitti da pagare eccetera eccetera
non riesce neppure a lavorare bene e
servono soldi
appunto diciamo vivere almeno sei sette
mesi senza stipendio io sono partito del
tfr quindi diciamo più o meno alto però
questo è l'ostacolo più grande è il
ruolo almeno nel mio caso ma anche
parlando con tante persone che ogni
tanto mi chiedono consigli
il ruolo mi piace la definizione da
wikipedia non ci vedo perché vado più
vicino e lascio il rituale il concetto e
definisce l'insieme dei comportamenti
attesi degli obblighi e delle
aspettative
attenzione obblighi aspettative che
convergono sull'individuo che ricopre
una determinata posizione sociale
spesso è alta associato al concetto di
stato
che cosa vuol dire questo che noi siamo
in una prova zona di comfort e spesso
indipendentemente da quello che facciamo
e che comunque abbiamo un ruolo è uno
status della società per quello che è
quello per cui i nostri amici la società
e conoscente eccetera ci conoscono se io
faccio il meccanico o la mia professione
di meccano o alla mia officina sono un
dipendente di fare nelle marche io c'ho
un ruolo uno status
attenzione più alto è il mio ruolo nella
nella società o nella della professione
è più difficile abbandonarlo
perché quando si riparte da zero si
riparte da zero
io avevo una bella professione prima di
mettermi in proprio guadagniamo bene il
direttore commerciale macchine eccetera
eccetera sono ripartito con mil dandomi
ma perché diciamo quello era 1.050 euro
al mese meno male che siamo tra i sette
otto mesi poi abbiamo iniziato che
volevano a fatturare e il mio collega
850 peccare più giovane aveva meno meno
esigenze quindi ripartire da zero vuol
dire in so per esempio passare da una
macchina bella ad un fiorino arancione
tipo anas come quello che avevo comprato
e l'altro problema è uscire dalla zona
di comfort
ripartire da zero vuol dire uscire dalla
propria zona di romford
quindi come fare allora io ho detto vado
alta dx teteks
e ho una piccola rubrica di suggerimenti
sono solo 7 non vi preoccupate
o dei suggerimenti da dare che sono
dettati dall'esperienza e come dice
sempre un amico veneto tosto è genuino
arcangelo l'esperienza è una sede di
testate hai battuto nella vita e ti
hanno fatto a prendere la sensibilità
nel capire dove sono i muri
questo è è ed è vero e quindi ho pensato
in questo momento di give back cioè
voglio restituire qualcosa della fortuna
ha avuto cerco di
dire come in un videogame a più persone
possibile dove ho trovato i muri quindi
di farglieli evitare allora attenzione
io parlo di intraprendere nell'età di
mezzo se poi uno il giovane a tutte
altre dinamiche e alla mente può battere
state ancora per tanti anni
se uno inizia a battere al 45 50 anni si
fa male
allora il primo consiglio ne do perché a
me ha portato fortuna e coinvolgete un
collaboratore più giovane d uomo molto
più giovane io avevo coinvolto un
collaboratore di vent'anni più giovane
di me che ancora li e che sta lavorando
ho fatte
perché perché c'è una differente energia
vivo in volgerà con differente diverso
entusiasmo
noi dobbiamo io sono consapevole di
essere diversamente giovane ed è diverso
da essere giovani e quindi ci vuole
pazienza ma ti dà una spaventosa ha una
capacità di proprio in soldi che noi
alcune volte ce la sogniamo
nessuno migliora invecchiando
quindi questo è il primo suggerimento il
secondo suggerimento è
non abbiate paura di regalare delle
quote della società dell'azienda
della ditta che mettete in piedi piccole
ruote dimostra di essere apache aprire
il capitale della società vuol dire
dargli un obiettivo un commitment verso
il futuro
renderlo veramente partecipe del futuro
il terzo è un po più
alcuni mi dicono no ma non lo devi dire
io invece lo diro
partendo nell'età di mezzo deleghe a
iniziamo a pensare ad un meccanismo di
delega verso i collaboratori
io quando sono partita eravamo due ora
siamo 90 ho iniziato un po tardi e sono
ancora a lavorare ma se avessi iniziato
prima sarebbe stato meglio a delegare
perché a meno che non vogliate fare come
qualcuno cambiare in mente godi insomma
che è morto costruendo a te bra le se
uno vuole anche assicurare al futuro
all'azienda e crea perché comunque
l'imprenditore c'è una forte
responsabilità sociale
ora io c'ho 90 persone che lavorano e
che prendono lo stipendio e hanno delle
famiglie non si può pensare di essere
eterni oppure di essere eternamente luci
di
quanto questo anche il problema no
dell'imprenditoria italiana ogni tanto
nessuno molla
e poi si muore
andate a caccia delle giuste relazioni
molto spesso si rifiutiamo chiti da
10mila euro
per entrare in società e chi invece non
te li da ma per esempio c'è un
patrimonio di relazioni per cui si
aprono teatro determinato mercato cioè
le relazioni in network delle persone è
importante tanto quanto sono importanti
i soldi o in questo ultimo periodo della
mia vita appunto incontrato delle
persone a cui sinceramente abbiamo dato
fiducia ma sanno anche ripagato con
tanto anche business del lavoro
ecco questa è una cosa e tengo
a cui tengo fartela mentre lo story
telling
il raccontare la storia dell'impresa lo
story telling è importantissimo però è
tanto più importante quanto è più
trasparente
noi quando andiamo a raccontare cosa
facciamo specialmente se iniziamo la
nostra età dobbiamo
non dobbiamo essere troppo marchettari e
dire a un guarda io sono azienda l'ho
aperto ora ma siamo di 170 persone cioè
preceda perché ci sgamano come si dice
in toscana noi bisogna essere
trasparenti bisogna essere orgogliosi di
raccontare all'interlocutore e abbiamo
che possono essere dalla parte fornitori
dall'altra gli enti
lo sforzo che stiamo facendo dobbiamo
trasferire indipendentemente da quelle
facciamo e può essere il lavaggio auto
4.0 o la società la startup innovativa
che utilizza le biotecnologie
di trasferire la passione con cui lo
stavo facendo una storia bella vera se
mai iniziata dolorosamente perché ho
perso il lavoro
perché dovevo cambiare vita
questo è un messaggio ne arriva perché
davanti a voi spesso ci sono persone
hanno i vostri stessi problemi
quindi paga di più essere trasparenti e
lo story telling in questo aiuta
il penultimo è quindi ci siamo quasi
quando pensate di abbandonare oppure ci
sono momenti critici crisi eccetera
dovete avere sempre in mente il motivo
per cui siete partiti
dove lo dovete tenere qui nell'emisfero
destro del cervello
nel cuore e scritto perché siete partiti
se volessi fare il figo l'idea è questa
è la mission
però nei momenti critici è meglio
chiamarlo motivo ascoltatemi credetemi e
mi piace anche farvi vedere due mission
di aziende americane perché rendono bene
l'idea a me mi piace tornare su questo
tema wal mart è il più grande e la più
grande azienda e grande distribuzione
del mondo in america ma anche del mondo
la sua mission
di
50 anni fa era dare alla gente comune la
possibilità di acquistare le stesse cose
dei ricchi
quindi fare dei supermercati dove chi
non ha uno stipendio da nababbo può
permettersi comunque togliersi delle
soddisfazioni ma la più bella in
assoluto
eccole vivo il disney che non è fare il
film fa cartone rendere felici le
persone
questo io quando sono partito ci avevo
questa missione di costruire un centro
di eccellenza sulle tecnologie di
identificazione automatica e sapevo a
malapena che cos'erano per le aziende
del fashion e del latte nei momenti di
crisi e le difficoltà non siamo andate a
cercare i mercati abbiamo battuto la
testa e siamo rimasti lì è
effettivamente questo ha pagato
l'ultimo consiglio molto pratico e
lavoriamo lavorate sulle nicchie
se io lavoro sulla nicchia posso fare
economie di scala
posso sfruttare il network di conoscenze
posso elaborare un'idea che davvero è
funzionale per quel target di
riferimento
faccio sempre questo esempio io sono un
ciclista io no ma insomma e sto pensando
di fare un azienda
costruendo una borraccia che mi possa
permettere di bere durante le pedalate
senza toccare senza toccare le mani voi
mi dite c'è camelback sì ma che cosa c'è
il filo e la pompa poi si schiaccia
certo no borracci innovativa state
sicuri che se io sono un ciclista
disegnano quella borraccia mettendo
tutti i problemi ho incontrato durante
la mia passione cioè cinismo e quella
borraccia anche se volessi voglio andare
a venderla il corridore piuttosto che a
chi fa trekking sarà sempre più adatta
per il cileno e io saprò parlare la
stessa lingua questo è un esempio
stupido ma secondo me è
fa parte diciamo dei miei suggerimenti
dettati dall'esperienza
sempre walt disney uno dei miei
preferiti diceva la strada giusta per
mettersi in attività e smettere di
parlare e cominciare a fare
mettere in piedi un'impresa nell'età di
mezzo vuol dire rinunciare a tante cose
ma è una roba gratificante vederla
crescere fatturare
vederla crescere fatturare è una roba
fantastica
per cui torna il mio mantra di sempre se
ce l'ho fatta io state tranquilli che ce
la potete fare anche voi
con minori difficoltà di me grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]